Build it, draw it, play it.
Vsauce, this is your home
for some of the coolest creations
from everyday people.
This is BIDIPI.
Build it—Justin Beckerman
is a high school student
who built his own submarine
that he actually uses.
He spent a month designing it
and five months building it.
The body of the submarine is
is a drain pipe,
it has a motor, regulators and valves
from an old soda machine,
three battery systems,
float sensors,
a horn, a CB radio to communicate
with people on the surface,
lights, and a camera system
that allows him to send a signal
to a TV for others to see
what he does,
and all of this set him back
around $950 dollars.
Rosanna Pansino creates pop culture
and video game-inspired cakes and cookies
on her show, Nerdy Nummies.
Her custom baked good creations include
Mario Piranha Cookie Pops,
Creeper Rice Krispie Treats,
and even an Indian Jones Monkey Brain cake.
And for the last episode
of BIDIPI,
she actually made
some Vsauce cupcakes.
Caleb from Hackaday created
an 80,000-volt homemade Thor hammer.
The head of the hammer is made from foam,
and the handle is PVC
wrapped in leather, with the battery located
in the bottom of the handle.
In the core of the hammer,
there's a built-in Tesla coil
that's able to power lightbulbs
and shock metal pieces.
Check out his channel
for more hacks.
Tom Eckert makes
extremely lifelike sculptures out of wood.
Some of his most impressive work
includes flowing forms,
like that of fabric, that look
as though they're translucent.
He uses traditional woodworking techniques
to create the pieces
and then paints them
with a waterborne lacquer
that he applies with both an airbrush
and brushes,
and he says that his preferred woods
are basswood, linden,
and lime-wood, because they're stable
and carve well.
Draw it—Kirsten of Chicago created
this delightful series of illustrations
of what famous TV
and movie characters do on their days off.
They include Alien takes Jonesy
to the Vet,
Michael irons the Jumpsuit,
and the Twin Peaks homage,
Bedtime for Log.
LA-based Dan Luvisi created
these nightmare pop culture character illustrations,
including Donald Duck, Yoshi,
and this one, called Nightmare Finn,
where he says, "The idea here
is that Finn devoured Jake,
consuming his abilities, and thus turning
into this huge creep."
And now
for some retro video game-themed art
from the IAM8BIT entertainment system
art show.
[♪ music ♪]
[♪ music continues ♪]
[PIXEL VISION]
8Bit Ego has an awesome series
called Pixel Vision
where Josh and Masood take turns
creating video game character artwork,
including SackBoy and Bison
and Donkey Kong.
Play it—
this 22,000-pound soil compactor
was converted
into a huge music box
that plays the Star Spangled Banner
by artist David Cole.
[♪ Star Spangled Banner ♪]
[♪ Star Spangled Banner continues ♪]
Jimmy DiResta, a guitar designer,
turned an AK47
into a functional guitar
for Wyclef Jean.
[guitar sounds]
[guitar sounds continue]
Here's the video
for Sam Westphalen's guitar/percussion cover
of Pantera's "Mouth for War."
♪ Hands break to hone raw energy. ♪
♪ Bold and disastrous. ♪
♪ My ears can't hear what you say to me. ♪
[♪ music ♪]
♪ Hold your mouth for the war. ♪
♪ Use it for what it's for. ♪
♪ Speak the truth about me. ♪
♪ Determined. ♪
Finally, here's the video
for "Plastic and Flashing Lights
by Professor Kliq
with animation by Victor Haegelin.
[♪ music ♪]
[♪ music continues ♪]
So leave your BIDIPIs as a personal message
here on YouTube,
or share them with everyone
over at Facebook.com/VsauceTwo.
[♪ The Man with the Machine Gun ♪]
[♪ music continues ♪]
Click here to listen
to a brand new installment
of BIDIPI Radio, music created
and submitted by you guys.
Also, check out Your BIDIPI,
an entire video dedicated
to your creations,
and as always, thanks for watching.
[Vsauce 2]
[Your BiDiPi]
[Click to Listen to BiDiPi Radio]
[Doni's Music]
[♪ music ♪]
[♪ music continues ♪]